[Music]
[Music]
no offense but air quality in China is
not great people are actually buying
bottled Canadian air for big bucks
la air is crap too we've got a natural
gas leak that won't be fixed for months
people here love to be organic AF so
I've come up with an ingenious product
for LA citizens artisanal air fresh
organic single source take a whiff you
deserve it
oh you want to sit in that chair cool me
too actually I don't like sharing get
the [ __ ] out of my chair it's the new
year I want to be eating more vegetables
I want them to be super colorful so I
came to a grilled cheese place to make
the most colorful cheese sandwich I
could ever make carrots
for spice as impossible it is to make a
blue cheese spread what does happened
here I asked for vegetable I got a
purple cheese sandwich this is not a
boulder and the rate of up so for those
of you trying to eat more vegetables in
2016 I highly recommend doing it in
grilled cheese for Kevin let's say good
day or bad day
[Music]
it was a good day why well first of all
North Korea claims they test in an
h-bomb but I'm not convinced it's
anything other than a viral promotional
stuff for the next Godzilla movie
there's a press conference in Oregon by
a Native American tribe who thought it
was pretty rich that all of these white
European dudes and beards and they are
claiming they're their original owners
of the land also there's a big puddle in
England then everybody's freaking out
these are all at all a banner day
[Music]
you